how are you
what's up everyone carlos bustamante
here simulu celebrated
two milestones yesterday number one his
birthday happy belated
and number two marvel studios dropped
the surprise teaser trailer
for simu's big marvel movies debut
and the legend of the 10 rings so in
honor of those milestones let's take a
look at some things we noticed
from the teaser trailer this is e.t
canada's nerdfight
i gave you 10 years to live your life
and where did that get you okay so some
basics first shanxi is a martial artist
trained by the ten rings organization
which is led by a long-standing
mcu villain mandarin whoa whoa whoa he's
here he's here
but he's not here he's here but he's not
here what do you mean it's complicated
hey it's complicated it's complicated no
not that guy
remember ben kingsley's mandarin was a
bait and switch move that fans still
debate to this day
well marvel plans on making good on
their promise to introduce the real
mandarin
and if you've been waiting all these
years to see the real deal
this shot right here hopefully made your
day son
it's time for you to take your place by
my side
that legendary chinese actor tony lung
stepping into the role of one woo
wearing the ten rings on his forearms
instead of on his fingers like in the
comics
in traditional kung fu rings like these
are used for strength training
i can't help but feel like there are
nods of the classic martial arts movie
the 36th chamber of shaolin oh
and i should mention that in this movie
the mandarin also happens to be shanxi's
dad
can i say i don't think their reunion is
going to go so well
i trained you
so the most dangerous people in the
world
[Music]
couldn't kill you a couple of those most
dangerous people are death dealer in the
mask there
and creed 2 star florian mantianu as
razorfist who
really lives up to his name later in the
trailer and further making it a family
affair
this looks to be shanghi's sister xiao
ling who's showing her bro who's boss
now to one of my favorite details this
film will have
giant animals so after pausing and
re-pausing these look like they could be
guardian lions
a version of stone lion statues brought
to life obviously we don't know
a lot about how these particular fight
scenes fit into the film well
anything at all really but i'm looking
forward to seeing this big battle
sequence as much as the smaller
one-on-one fights
now we first meet shanghai after he's
been away from his father for 10 years
choosing to live a life with maybe less
crime and assassins
and more partying and karaoke and i mean
any life that brings you closer to being
bffs with aquafina is
in my opinion a total win and yes look
closely
they're seeing a whole new world in that
karaoke scene
synergy on
a magic carpet ride
a whole new world
we make a good team something else to
note is that we only see simu in the
shanghai costume from the poster for a
brief moment in a fight with what looks
like wenmu
so of course we'll get a closer look at
that in action in upcoming full-length
trailers
director dustin daniel [ __ ] drew
inspiration from a variety of sources
when it came to the fight scenes
since chongqi is a master at several
different types of martial arts
fans can expect to see the elegant
ethereal wushu style of crouching tiger
hidden dragon
as well as the kinetic choreography of
jackie chan's action comedies
and since shanxi in the comics has
always been marvel's answer to bruce lee
looks like we're getting a healthy dose
of shirtless simu as well
what'd you think are you as excited as i
am with shanichi being the first marvel
movie led by an asian cast and director
marvel is continuing to make good in the
promise to diversify the mcu
and that's something to celebrate let me
know your thoughts in the comments and
be sure to catch our the falcon in the
winter soldier finale recap on friday
and our round table talk about the end
of the series on tuesday april 27th that
one's new you're gonna want to watch
that
thanks for watching everyone i'll see
you next time
[Music]